[Music]
if we are given this image and asked
what exactly this is I'm sure your
answer will be a cell
now to study this we need to study every
component present within and not only
within we even need to study the
covering that is this part in detail now
can you tell me what exactly is this
named as that's right it's called the
cell membrane or the plasma membrane
in our previous video we have learnt
that the cell membrane is selectively
permeable in nature that is it only
allows specific materials to enter and
leave the cell any guesses what is the
plasma membrane made up of the plasma
membrane is made up of lipids and
proteins and also has some carbohydrate
chains there are two things that freely
move in and out of the cell those
include gases and water do you think
these molecules need energy for
travelling across the membrane let's
take a simple example to understand what
exactly happens in this case we know
what happens when a drop of ink is added
to a glass of water
the single dark colored ink drop spreads
when added to water and the intense blue
color fades slightly if we see at the
molecular level then the ink molecules
which are compactly packed in the single
drop get a chance of dispersing in a
larger area when added to the water this
is nothing but the process of diffusion
and we know that this dispersal process
does not require energy the molecules
just try to move freely in the space
available and as a result diffusion
occurs the same story is seen when gas
or water molecules travel across the
membrane take carbon dioxide for example
when cells undergo cellular respiration
a lot of carbon dioxide accumulates in
the cell on the other hand there is very
little carbon dioxide present outside
the cells
hence the carbon dioxide molecules move
outside the cells now there is very
little oxygen left after respiration in
the cells so the oxygen from outside the
cells moves in through the plasma
membrane to make up for the lost oxygen
that means carbon dioxide moves out and
oxygen moves in both the gases move from
their area of higher concentration to an
area of lower concentration and this
diffusion process does not require
energy diffusion is one of the processes
by which transportation of several
substances is carried out across the
cell membrane but it's not the only one
process on which the cell relies there
are a few more methods that the cell
adopts for transportation of substances
let's have a look at these processes in
the next video
[Music]
you